whatever chuck schumer always makes me
feel better
make no mistake there will be a trial
and when that trial ends
senators will have to decide if they
believe
donald john donald john trump incited
the erection
well i mean you're right and certain
erection every night ask milania
and she's like it's not true he gets a
tolerance maybe three times a year it's
not true
the last time his penis was hired was
when baron was conceived
on trump incited the erection
insurrection wow chuck seems like you're
really obsessed with my penis
you get my penis and the brain check
can i say that i am actually this is one
of the saddest things to me that trump
isn't on twitter right now
because i would love all the crazy [ __ ]
that would be happening chuck schumer
disgraced himself in his office today
by going on an entire day trip about my
penis
and frankly i don't think he's fit to
serve take your penis out of my mouth
chuck
well now that he's not president i
really wish he was on twitter because
now he could really go ham
what is it about these
jesus you imagine
insurrection against the united states
he's trying not to laugh because he even
he knows he said erection
hallowed halls folks this is our
congress
this is our senate enjoy enjoy the clown
world we live in now
i think it's pretty dope
it's okay mike i think people need to
[ __ ] be grateful that we get to live
in the silliest [ __ ] time in
in history i already have a backup plan
i'm going to tech school to become a
fracker
so i'm good to go oh that's probably a
bad idea
i heard it's like booming in new mexico
right were booming in
in mexico sure go for it no new mexico
oh yeah you don't want to go there
i would i would do more research before
you sure land on a career yeah
i don't know man there's a lot of money
you know you're helping the energy
industry
forget it you know what i get that
that's rough
here's what i'm gonna do i've decided
i'm gonna go help build the keystone
pipeline
because that will make us energy
destruction yeah that's good
yeah that'll make us energy independent
and we'll go from there
look i'm just gonna tell you this folks
you
are uh in an unprecedented time of
history
there is a uh this is a
economic turmoil right now and these uh
lazy people in congress cannot get your
stimulus checks right
but they'll sit around and talk about my
penis all day
in fact they think it's disgraceful uh
well hey there's some good stuff
is there no i'm not even gonna do it
anymore there's just it's all bad it's
it's stupid and it's not lying to the
people